marzak bonsoir vous êtes ministre de la
santé de la famille vous est également
médecin gynécologue alors le problème de
ce qu'on appelle des mst notamment du
sida ce je pense au coeur de vos
préoccupations
on va pas parler politique se soit on
aimerait entendre du concret de votre
part alors d'abord question importante
est ce que le sida les mst sont un
dossier prioritaire pour vous bien sûr
c'est un dossier très important
quelques chiffres un peu le sida de
nouveaux cas de sida par semaine en
france actuellement
et fin 87 200 mille personnes porteuses
du virus donc c'est ce qu'on appelle les
séropositifs faisons pas forcément
malades qui ne sont pas malades et qui
sont et qui vivent tout à fait
normalement et je crois qu'il faut faire
ce soir c'est de ne pas être d'essayer
de ne pas faire les missions de la peur
mais simplement l'émission de la
formation si vous voulez bien nous
n'avons jamais fait mention de la peur
et cette machine à la réunion je le
précise le jo si de la cam simplement
mon rien un problème qui se pose où les
10 vous même êtes vous en mesure par
exemple aujourd'hui d'offrir un accueil
on parle je crois de cinq mille malades
dans les deux années à venir avec moi
même d'offrir un accueil à ces gens là
je crois qu'il ya deux problèmes il ya
d'abord celui des personnes qui vous
protège et aujourd'hui et puis il ya
ceux des malades ceux de est malade
effectivement on parle de 5000 personnes
pour la fin 88
aujourd'hui on peut accueillir les
malades qui sont atteints et donc c'est
j'ai l'intention de prévoir les
possibilités d'accueil c'est à dire des
lits et puis des centres de ce qu'on
appelle des centres de dépistage de
référence qui pourront permettre aux
malades d'abord d'être vus ensuite être
dirigés vers des services qui sont les
services spécialisés mais vous savez le
problème du sida c'est surtout avant
tout un problème de prévention
c'est un problème d'information ce qu'il
faut savoir on l'a dit tout à l'heure
c'est que il attendait des catégories de
population qui sont très exposés on a
parlé des homosexuels on a parlé des
toxicomanes
je voudrais dire une chose parce qu'elle
est très importante c'est que les jeunes
sont exposés maintenant parce qu'on
appelle la toxicomanie occasionnels une
seringue qui passe une fois comme ça au
cours d'une soirée et on peut être
contaminée et donc on peut être porteur
du virus avis et ça je crois que c'est
important de le savoir
la deuxième chose c'est que bien sûr que
ce sont des populations exposées mais
que de plus en plus on voit apparaître
des porteurs de germes il est voire des
maladies dans une population qui n'a pas
n'est pas homosexuel qui n'est pas
toxicomane
donc il faut commencer a multiplié les
moyens d'information et de prévention
alors parlons prévention car c'est le
vrai problème aujourd'hui pour la
chaleur des moyens d'accueil connaît
rapidement évoquée par l'ons prévention
on sait comment faire pour éviter tout
coup le sida on sait que le problème
préservatif est essentiel dans cette
affaire en france c'est pas toujours
facile c'est vrai que le préservatif
c'est le meilleur moyen de prophylaxie
vous savez qu'il ya une loi qui interdit
la publicité quelques interdit de dire
que les préservatifs sont un moyen de
prophylaxie contre les maladies
sexuellement transmissibles ce que le
médecin commence toujours et j'ai
l'intention d'abroger cette loi de telle
façon que l'on puisse vraiment faire
d'informations à ce sujet qu'on puisse
bien expliquer que c'est le seul moyen
de protection dont nous disposons
concrets dont nous disposons aujourd'hui
de dire que l'on peut faire de là pour
faire de la publicité pour les
préservatifs ce qui est nouveau en
france on pour interdire la zunie déjà
contre à faire de la publicité pour les
préservatifs moyen de prophylaxie et
puis là donc les toxicomanes dont vous
parliez bon l'autre l'idée qui est dans
l'air c'est le problème des soeurs un
aigle disiez vous même une seringue
occasionnels c'est une aiguille qui
tourne et c'est bien souvent donc ou
pire le sida et éventuellement d'autres
maladies alors est ce qu'on peut
imaginer un jour qu'on puisse se trouver
des sarts des seringues et aiguilles en
tant que livre en france on en parlera
je crois que pour l'instant personne
n'est tout à fait prêts à cela et donc
je crois que c'est vraiment un sujet
dont il faut parler mais qui est
certainement très qui a son intérêt dans
dans des problèmes de contamination du
sida et qu'il faudra revoir le besoin
qu'a tout dernier mot et de conflits
magie de voir en france des centres de
traitements du sida comme on a vu des
centres anticancéreux par exemple on
peut déjà dans un premier temps voire
des centres de dépistage et on verra des
services spécialisés dans l'âme et 10 du
sida traitement des maladies du sida car
vous savez que ça appelle un certain
nombre de précautions notamment
2 pour le personnel hospitalier non pas
pour lui même car il n'est pas du tout
exposé vous avez bien vu qu'on attrape
pas le sida comme ça par contact et
simplement ça pose un certain nombre de
règles très précises et hospitalière
d'hygiène et donc on verra les centres
spéciaux
madame barzakh à la ministe merci
d'arrêter notre invité ce soir donc
alors que s'ouvre ce congrès à paris ce
congrès sur la recherche sur le sida et
puis cette information qui vous
intéresse ou goût